Moment.
Bitte schön.
Okay.
Schönen guten Abend.
Ich heiße Mustafa Günes.
Ich bin hier Auto Station als Assistenzarzt tätig.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Ist das Ihnen ordentlich für Sie?
Ja, hauptsache ich jemand Koktage und Hürtmehe.
Ja, ja gerne.
Bevor Ihre aktuelle Beschwerdenwürdig, Ihre persönliche Daten verraten, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Marta Baumgart.
Marta M-A-R-T-A.
M-M am Anfang, ne?
Ja.
Und Ihr...
T-H-A mit TH-Sprachmann Marta.
Marta.
Und Ihre Nachname können Sie langsam...
Baumgart.
Baum wie der Baum, B-A-U-M-G-A-R-T.
T-A-R-T Baumgart.
Genau, ja.
Frau Baumgart, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 16 Jahre.
Schön.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 8. Februar, 58.
58.
Na gut.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,56.
56.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Muss ich Ihnen das verraten?
Ja, ja, es wäre toll, wenn Sie es haben.
Ja, es sind 84 Kilo.
Wie bitte? Ich habe apostisch nicht gehört.
84 Kilo.
80.
Okay, gut.
Frau Baumgart, was bingst du zu uns?
Was will beschwerten haben Sie denn?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe heute...
habe ich meine Küche sauber gemacht.
Also so eine schwere Sprudelkiste
von einer Seite auf die andere gestellt.
Und mit einmal hatte ich solche Schmerzen hier oben in der Brust.
Und das strahlte in den ganzen Armen rein.
Und mir war...
Also wirklich schlecht.
Als ich mich ein bisschen hingesetzt habe,
ist es wieder besser geworden.
Aber das hat mir schon für den Augenblick
das große Angst gemacht.
Das waren wirklich starke Schmerzen.
Aber es ist dann zum Glück wieder weggegangen.
Und haben Sie noch nie erlebt?
Nein, so was habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay.
Und die Strahlen schmerzen in Ihren linken Armen?
In den linken Armen.
Das ging sogar so ein bisschen hoch,
so am Hals bis zum Kind, bis zum Unterkiefer so hin.
Frau Baumgart,
ich möchte das Anamnasegespräch unterbrechen,
um Ihre wichtige Werte zu messen.
Ihre Puls und Ihre Fieber, Brutdruck und Ihr Atmung.
Okay.
Ja.
Gut, Arut, hast du das gemacht?
Ich habe die Monitor anschließen und machen wir so weiter.
Okay, gut. Das machen wir jetzt.
Frau Baumgart,
haben Sie schon,
sind Sie schon einmal beim Hausarzt gelesen?
Nein, deswegen nicht.
Das hat mir solche Angst gemacht, dass ich direkt hierher gekommen bin.
Fühlen Sie sich enge Gefühle in der Boot?
Ja, es waren wirklich starke Schmerzen.
Okay.
Das habt ihr gezogen, wissen Sie?
Als ob der jemand an mir zieht, so hat sich das angefühlt.
Okay, Siehende.
Wie beschreiben Sie noch die Schmerzen, sind Sie herstechend, drückend und pochend?
Nein, pochend nicht.
Pochend nicht und stechend eigentlich auch nicht.
So ziehen drückend, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Ich habe ein bisschen rumgeräumt und habe diese schwere Kiste verschoben.
Mit einem Mal fing das an und musste ich mich erst mal hinsetzen.
Dann ging es aber zum Glück nachher weg und dann habe ich jetzt erst mal Pause gemacht.
Sind die Schmerzen immer noch da?
Nein, jetzt ist es zum Glück weg.
Wie viele Minuten hat es gedauert?
Das kann ich gar nicht genau sagen.
Mir ist es früh bar lang vorgekommen.
Ich weiß aber, dass es tatsächlich nicht so lange war.
Ich habe dann nachher auf die Uhr geguckt und dann war eigentlich gar nicht so viel Zeit vergangen.
Mir kam es wie eine Ewigkeit vor.
Wahrscheinlich war das eine 50-Stunde.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Wie stark die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von ein bis zehn vorbei eins,
sehr leicht und sehr starker Schmerzen entspricht?
Für den Augenblick waren das schon starke Schmerzen.
Ich würde sagen sieben oder acht.
Dann ging es nachher wieder runter und jetzt habe ich keine Schmerzen mehr.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Nein, ich habe nur mal den normalen Medikamente eingenommen, die ich sonst auch einnehme.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Haben Sie weitere Beschwerden zum Beispiel, Übelkeit erbrechen?
Nein, das musste ich so nicht übergeben.
Das einzige, was mir aufgefallen ist, ist, dass ich so ein bisschen einen Husten habe.
Okay, haben Sie einen Husten? Seit wann?
Ja, eigentlich ist er jetzt kurzfristig, erst würde ich sagen, seit zwei Tagen.
Aber nach dieser Attacke hatte ich das Gefühl, dass ich mit einem so das Bedürfnis habe zu Husten.
Er hat Rücken oder mit Ausbruch?
Nein, es ist ganz trockener Husten, da kommt nichts.
Okay, leiten Sie einen Luftnot?
Nein, das hatte ich eigentlich auch nicht unterweh, als es war heute Morgen.
Ich hatte nicht das Gefühl, dass ich keine Luft kriege, das war nicht.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber, Schütterfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Schüttelfrost habe ich nicht, nachschweiß habe ich schon lange nicht mehr.
Also Fieber, ich habe es nicht gemessen, aber ich bin auch guter.
Bitte?
Fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Ich fühle mich nicht fieberig, nein.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, ich habe häufiger mal ein bisschen Verstopfung und beim Wasserlassen, ich muss halt schon 2-3 Mal in der Nacht auf die Toilette gehen.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, Beschwerden würde ich das jetzt nicht nennen.
Verstopfung habe ich eigentlich schon jahrelang und auch mit dem Nächtlichen auf die Toilette gehen.
Ja, ich würde vielleicht sagen, seit 3-4 Jahren.
Wie viele Mal müssen Sie aufklauen?
2-mal meistens in der Nacht, wenn es hoch kommt, 3-mal.
Okay, Frau Baumtath, haben Sie sonst noch etwas Beschwerden, von denen ich wissen musste?
Ja, also ich meine, dass, was jeder in meinem Alter hat, wissen Sie ja, der Blutdruck ist ein bisschen hoch
und die Blutfette sind ein bisschen erhöht.
Ich habe auch seit 10 Jahren Diabetes, also diesen Alterszucker, und muss dann regelmäßig mein Metformin einnehmen.
Und dann hatte ich mal Probleme mit den Gelenken und da hat mein Hausarzt festgestellt, dass ich so eine leichte Gicht habe.
Ah, okay.
Das kommt alles aber nicht immer, also das sind immer mal wieder, wenn ich ein bisschen gesündigt habe, sind das so Attacken.
Das ist damit einmal wieder weh tut, wenn ich mal viel Fleisch gegessen habe oder so.
Und wann war letzte Anfall?
Oh, das ist schon lange zurück, ich würde sagen, vielleicht halb, ja, viertel Jahr oder so.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruckdruck und Alterszucker?
Das hat man so ungefähr vor 10 Jahren festgestellt, ja, da war ich so, da war ich 56, da war das Jahr.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Metformin, wie viel?
Metformin nehme ich regelmäßig ja.
Wie sind Sie Dosierung?
500 nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Eigentlich haben wir das damit so ganz gut.
Gegen Blutdruck nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, da nehme ich morgens immer eine Tablette, weil da tagen.
Wie sind Sie Dosierung?
Ich meine, da steht 160 drauf.
160, einmal morgens oder abends?
Okay, gegen Gicht nehmen Sie etwas ein?
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das gegen die Gicht ist, ich nehme Pantorexal.
Aber ich glaube, das ist mehr so, wenn ich so mal ein bisschen sauren Magen habe.
Wie viel Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Ich nehme das, wenn ich regelmäßig, ich nehme das immer nur, wenn ich so ein bisschen so saures Aufstufen mal habe.
600 steht da, glaube ich, drauf, Pantorexal 600.
Okay, leiden Sie an Aufstoßen oder Notbrinnen auch?
Ja, manchmal habe ich das.
Also jetzt auch nicht, aber wie gesagt manchmal.
Dagegen nehmen Sie Pantoprasol oder so, oder?
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Ja, und wenn das mit der Verdauung nicht klappt, da habe ich solche Beutelchen, das heißt Movicol, das kann ich dann einnehmen, wenn ich mal Verstopfen habe.
Aber nehmen Sie keine Medikamente gegen Gicht?
Nein, nein, hat mein Haus aus mir nichts verschrieben.
Okay, verstehe ich.
wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, mehr als genug.
Ich hatte eine Gebärmutter-Senkung,
dann hat man die Gebärmutter entfernt, das ist jetzt neun Jahre her.
Und dann habe ich vor acht Jahren auf der linken Seite ein neues Kniegelenk bekommen.
Okay.
Ansonsten hatten Sie keine OP?
Nein, das waren die beiden Operationen, genau.
Okay.
Bauband hat, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauch eigentlich gar nicht.
Haben Sie noch nie genau geraucht, meine Sie?
Nein, früher habe ich mal geraucht.
Also ein paar Jahre lang habe ich einfach nie viel, immer nur so 15 Zigaretten am Tag oder so, aber jetzt seit zehn Jahren rauchen ich schon nicht mehr.
Okay.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht, ein paar Jahre haben Sie gesagt, oder?
Ja, also so sporadisch geraucht habe ich schon so als junge Frau und dann habe ich es mir irgendwann angewöhnt, vielleicht so 20 Jahre.
Das hat 20 Jahre gedauert, 20 Jahre haben Sie gedauert?
Ja, ich denke 20 Jahre, weil das ist so von 30 bis 50 und oder sogar noch ein bisschen länger, 35 bis 55.
Und jetzt vor zehn Jahren war ich sehr stolz, als Sie es aufgehört haben.
Sie haben eine sehr gute Entscheidung getroffen, ja.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ach, man gibt es schon mal etwas zu feiern, also eigentlich trinke ich nicht viel Alkohol, vielleicht mal, ja, wenn es Malengläse gibt oder wenn es zum Guten Essen, wenn ich mal eingeladen bin, wenn es da Malenglässchen Wein gibt oder so.
Ja, ich trinke nicht regelmäßig, überhaupt nicht regelmäßig Alkohol.
Ah, okay.
Okay, elegantlich meinen Sie prima.
Gut, nehmen Sie die folgende Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage, aber Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen sehe ich so aus, nein, nein, also wirklich nicht mehr.
Nein, mit Drogen habe ich keinen Glück.
Gut.
Frau Baumtath, leiden Sie Ihre erlten chronische Erkrankungen wie zum Beispiel Altezuka oder vererbliche Erkrankungen?
Boah, ich hoffe nicht, meine Mutter hatte Leberkrebs und die ist gar nicht alt geworden, die ist mit 60 gestorben.
Und mein Vater, auch da hoffe ich, dass er das für sich behalten hat, dass ich das nicht erbe oder geerbt habe.
Mein Vater, der ist schon hoch betagt, der ist 90 Jahre alt, aber der ist jetzt wirklich sehr dement und ist im Pflegeheim, aber das ist eigentlich auch eine traurige Geschichte.
Leidet er an chronische Erkrankungen?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, sonst wäre er nicht so alt geworden, also das Problem ist eben die Dement.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Eine Schwester habe ich ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Sie ist ein bisschen jünger als ich.
Ja, die hatte tatsächlich vor, guck mal, wenn Sie sagen, ist das her, das ist jetzt ein gutes Jahr her.
Da hatte die mal so ein Herzinfarkt, aber die hat sie gut überstanden, die haben sie dann versorgt im Krankenhaus und seither geht, also muss sie natürlich ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, aber sie hat das alles überstanden.
Okay, in Ordnung.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Oder sind Sie aktuell im Renten?
Ich bin schon im Renten, ja.
Bevor, was haben Sie gemacht?
Ich habe als Schneiderin gearbeitet.
Schneiderin?
Ja.
Ein bisschen was mache ich, also so privat mache ich immer noch ein bisschen was, so nebenher, so viel, wie es geht.
Okay, gut, schön.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verwitted, weil man hatte vor zwei Jahren ein Autounfall und seitdem bin ich alleine.
Tut mir wirklich sehr leid, ich habe kein Beileid.
Frau, wann tat?
Brauben Sie Kinder?
Ja, unsere vier Kinder, das ist unsere große Freude, ja.
Sie sind aber natürlich schon groß und sie sind aus dem Haus.
Sind Sie gesund?
Na das will ich hoffen, ja, ja, also klar, sind Sie gesund, ja.
Sie sind ja noch jung.
Das freut mich sehr.
Leiden Sie sich an viel Stress im Alltag?
Nein, das kann ich so wirklich nicht sagen.
Seit ich nicht mehr arbeite, habe ich es ja eigentlich gut.
Kann ich mir meinen Tag gut anteilen?
Nein, Stress habe ich wirklich nicht.
Okay, treiben Sie regentmäßig Sport?
Nicht wirklich, nein.
Ah, schade.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ich weiß, mir hat mal jemand gesagt, das habe ich seither auch nicht wieder genommen.
Ich darf kein Penicillin nehmen.
Ah, okay.
Wie öfter hat sich Ihre Penicillin-Allergie?
Ja, das ist schon lange her.
Aber ich meine, dass ich mit einer so ganz roten, heißen Gesicht bekommen habe
und so beginnt eine pelzige Zunge.
Das haben die aber irgendwie gleich gemerkt.
Und dann hat man mir irgendwas dagegen gegeben, glaube ich.
Also jedenfalls ist das da nicht schlimmer geworden.
Ja, war das unglaublich für Sie, oder?
Ja, natürlich, unheimlich, ja klar.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten?
Kinderkrankheiten, schon momentär mit den Kinderkrankheiten.
Aber eigentlich habe ich da, ja, hat man ja zu der Zeit alles gemacht.
Man hat ja alle Impfungen bekommen.
Und jetzt in letzter Zeit habe ich natürlich auch alle meine Corona-Enfungen wahrgenommen.
Wie seid ihr vorbei?
Okay, wir sind fast fertig.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Naja, ich möchte natürlich schon wissen, ob sowas wiederkommen kann
und ob das schlimm ist und ob das vielleicht so etwas ist
wie bei meiner Schwester mit ihrem Herzentakt.
Das macht mir natürlich Angst.
Ja, ja, verstehe ich Ihre Sorge, Frau Bamthack.
Es ist so früh, etwas genau zu sagen.
Ich muss ein paar Untersuchungen bei Ihnen durchführen.
Blutuntersuchungen, körperliche Untersuchungen, Bildgebende, Verfahren.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse vorliegen haben, werde ich mit meinem Obar
Ihrem Fallwäschchen brechen.
Und dann werde ich Sie Schritt für Schritt informieren.
Was Sie denn so haben.
Ja, das ist gut.
Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorge.
Warten Sie Ihren Untersuchungen, Sie meine ich komme gleich.
Sehr gut, okay.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Das hat lange gedauert, Herr Günthitz, aber es war glaube ich sehr vollständig.
Ja, 21 Minuten hat gedauert. 21 Minuten noch, 1 Minuten.
Im Limit.
Ja, aber im FESEP ist, sie läuft derzeit, 9, 10 Minuten.
Okay, sie sind streng, ja.
Aber ich habe auch einige sprächige Patientin, müssen Sie zugeben.
Ich denke keine Fragen.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass noch irgendwas offen ist.
Ich habe nichts mehr auf meinem Zettel.
Ne, wir sind noch nicht mehr.
Neue Husten?
Nein, immer noch beim alte Husten.
Alte Husten.
Ja, aber es passt weg.
Haben Sie Allergen oder?
Nein.
Sie sind nicht Raucherin, ich weiß.
Ja, ich bin nicht.
Es ist komisch, dass ich immer noch Husten.
Ja, aber ich versächt euch mal zum Arzt gehen.
Können wir ja als erstes, ich habe dir anfangen, Ginesch?
Ja, gut.
Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Abend Frau Obererstin.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit den Patienten vorstellen?
Aber ja, natürlich.
Den haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, Frau Marta Baumtath ist eine 66-jährige Patientin.
Er stellte sich bei uns in der Notaufnahme mit siehender, bestehender Retro-Sternar-Schmerzen
ausstrahlen und in linken Arm und sucken sie wieder vor.
Gleichzeitig klackt sie über Tussis seit zwei Tagen,
Obstibation seit langen und Nektürie.
Haben Sie denn gleich ein EKG gemacht?
Ja, ich habe sofort den Patienten den Monitor angeschlossen
und ihre Puls, Blöckdruck, Fieber und Atmung gemessen.
Und das war jetzt aber nicht mehr gravierend?
Ja, wir haben ein paar Befunde.
Okay, dann müssen wir gleich gucken. Dann erzählen Sie mal weiter.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt auf einer Schmerzskala bei 7-8.
Nein, eigentlich hat sie momentan keine Schmerzen.
Nach der starke Belastung zu Hause hat die Beschwerden angefangen.
Ansonsten war die vegetative Annamenise unauffällig.
An vor Erkrankungen berichtete die Patientin seit 10 Jahren
und die Hyperürike zu leiden.
Sie nehmen regelmäßig 500 mg morgens und abends,
bei 161 mg morgens und Panthoprosol 20 mg morgens.
Das sind regelmäßig Pantoprozol?
Panthoprosol bei Bedarf 1.
Die Frage nach Operation Geschichte.
Er gab eine Historektomie vor 9 Jahren und eine Knietep vor 8 Jahren.
Er raucht momentan nicht.
Er oder sie?
Sie.
Sie raucht momentan nicht.
Vor 10 Jahren hat sie aufgehört.
Vor 10 Jahren.
Vor 30 Jahren.
Sie trinken ein Glas Wein oder Säkt.
Der Drogenkondition wurde verneint.
Familienannamenistisch fand sich eine Demenz beim Vater der Patientin.
Deswegen ist er pflegebedürftig.
Sie berichtete, dass ihre Mutter an Leberkarzinom mit 60 verstorben.
Gleichzeitig berichtete der Patientin,
dass ihre Schwester an Leberkarzinfakt geliegt habe.
Aber beruflich ist sie als Schneiderin tätig.
Er ist verwirrt.
Sie ist verwirrt.
Sie hat vier gesunde Erwachsene Kinder.
Was vermutet ihr? Was steckt denn jetzt dahinter?
Ja, die anamnistischen Angaben durch den Arm,
sie sind eine stabile Angene Pektor.
Was könnte es noch sein?
Differenzial diagnostisch.
Hier kommt auch eine atypische Pynomene
oder eine akute Coronacendronin betrachtet.
Sehr gut, okay.
Was machen Sie mit der Patientin?
Ich würde gerne mit der Patientin eine EKG verlassen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich besonders
ein Lungengeräusche und Herzgeräusche.
Woher gucken Sie noch bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf,
eine Spontanpynomertraxonbeite zu haben.
Was würden Sie sich noch anschauen?
Bei der Untersuchung.
Ja, bei der Untersuchung als Bildgebende verfahren eine...
Ich meine mit Ihren Augen, ohne Bildgebung.
Was würden Sie angucken?
Oder vielleicht auch fühlen?
Untere Extremität.
Ja, untere Extremität, ein Beinödem, achte ich.
Genau, das meinte ich.
Und Herzinsubstitzenzeichen achte ich.
Ansonsten...
Was waren die Labortechnik?
In der Laborte, als Blutbild trockenen E und T.
Und CKMB, myoglobin.
Ansonsten ist es wichtig so überprüfen,
dass es eine Echokardiografie gibt.
Eine Echokardiografie.
Okay, gut.
Und EKG hatten wir schon gesagt.
Sehr gut.
Okay.
Und daran halten Sie mich auf dem Laubenden,
was mit der Patientin ist.
Nehmen wir die jetzt kurz für sich stationär aus?
Oder weil sie jetzt mehr schweil ist,
die Stationäreaufnahme unbedingt.
Und die Farbzugang und Flüssigkeit zuvor.
Und Morphine als Anälgedika.
Auch, weil sie jetzt keine Sperren zu haben?
Ja, nicht sofort, aber brauchen wir in der Überwachung.
Okay, ja.
Sauerstoffsetzung.
Sehr gut.
Gut, dann wie gesagt, berichten Sie mir über die Patientin,
wenn Sie Ihre Untersuchung abgeschlossen haben.
Ja?
Okay, gut.
Das war doch ziemlich schön.
Was mir aufgefallen ist,
das ist das, wo ich eben gerade auch nochmal nachgehakt habe.
Sie haben in der Anfangssequenz,
als Sie berichtet haben, haben Sie gesagt,
Sie hätte eben bestehende retroschrenalischen Schmerzen.
Aber die sind ja eigentlich,
hatte sie die Schmerzen in der Vergangenheit und hat angegeben,
jetzt ist es eigentlich nicht mehr schlimm.
Na?
Okay, wie richtig.
Ja, und das müsste man,
also müsste man sicherlich anders formulieren,
also bestehen die Schmerzen, das ist ja nicht.
Und deswegen auch jetzt natürlich keine Morphingabe.
Dann, wie kommen Sie auf die 30 Packiers?
Sie hat gesagt, dass Sie eine halbe Packung höchstens,
also 10 Zigaretten über 30 Jahren.
Ja, das heißt 20 Packiers, ja.
Nee.
Sie hat 20 Jahre geraucht.
Halbe Packung.
Aber halbe Packung, das ist 10 Packiers.
Ja, 10 Packiers, ja, das ist falsch.
Gut, und ansonsten gibt es aber, glaube ich,
also, ein paar Mal haben Sie jetzt zum Schluss dann Sie und er verwechselt,
aber ich denke mal, das kann passieren.
Ja, die Sache mit der Beinschwellung,
das haben Sie tatsächlich auch in der Analyse nicht gefragt,
das hat mich jetzt aufgefallen.
Und was Sie auch nicht gefragt haben,
ob die Angewicht zugelegt hat in letzter Zeit.
Das wäre ja auch noch interessant,
im Sinne von Wasserhandlagerung.
Ja, wegen der Udeme,
ja, Gewichtsunahme.
Ja, hatten Sie aber nicht gefragt
und Sie hat spontan ja auch nichts davon gesagt.
Wenn Sie jetzt gesagt hätten, ja, ich wiege mich regelmäßig
mal ist es höher und mal ist es,
dann hätten Sie natürlich nachgehört.
Es wäre toll, wenn ich gefragt hätte.
Ja, man kann nicht alles perfekt machen.
Aber ich fand eigentlich schon ein sehr gutes Gespräch.
Sie haben die Patientin sehr vollständig gefragt.
Sie waren sehr schön ruhig im Gespräch.
Sie mussten ein bisschen reinhören in Ihre Sprechweise.
Sie machen ein paar kleine Grammatikfehler.
Aber es ist nicht so etwas,
was jetzt Sinn entstellen ist oder so.
Und nach ganz kurzer Zeit konnte ich sie sehr gut verstehen.
Und sie haben mich, glaube ich, auch immer gut verstanden.
Was ich schön fand,
dass Sie im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch die Fachbegriffe
überwiegend verwendet haben.
Denn die Patientin hat ja eigentlich
alle so ein bisschen grob orientieren und ihren Worten geschildert.
Dafür ein bisschen mehr Worte.
Und das haben sie gut zusammengepackt
und haben es eben mit den Fachbegriffen,
ja, was Sie der Oberärzte nicht erzählt haben,
dass sie keine Luftnot hatte und dass sie keine MSS hatte.
Das haben sie nicht weitergegeben.
Dann Gewicht beinstellung habe ich gesagt.
Ja, ich glaube, das sind die einzigen kleinen Punkte,
an denen man ein bisschen rummerkeln kann.
Aber eigentlich würde ich mal sagen,
war das das schöne Anamnese
und auch ein gutes vollständiges Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Und Diagnose war natürlich auch richtig.
Das freut mich sehr.